but I've given you all the dirt
but we were not expecting to see you
here tonight
why is that I've never missed one before
and I'm not gonna miss one now because
some of your co-stars were yes
oh that saying all you effort has got a
show up listen I don't take my direction
from anybody okay I do what I want to do
and I'm here to support the show I'm not
here to socialize so to speak but the
show's been really good to me for eight
years our ninth season 330 episodes of
reality television and I love them and
they're like my family so I'm here to
support the show absolutely so you were
always going to show up tonight it
wasn't those tweets that got you here no
I don't you know I don't react to the
nonsense and all that aggressiveness you
know I the aggression that in that tweet
was really ugly as far as I understand
the tagline it's pretty epic
is that pointed at anybody in particular
just how I was feeling you know it's I
think that the tagline should reflect
your feelings of the season so that's
what I wanted to say and of course
sometimes Provost say oh you sure about
that yes I'm really sure I think the
message was loud and clear right how do
you feel about how Teddy's tagline came
after because that kind of seems like
maybe it was directed at you well I
haven't seen the episode so I only
really know my tag lines I haven't seen
the episode I chose not to watch
personally it was a very difficult time
in my life especially around the
beginning and filming so I've chosen not
to go back to that space are you gonna
watch any of the season or you just kind
of let it play out
when they've all ganged up on me before
like season two for six as we talked
about I got away with eight I probably
didn't watch that yeah so okay how do
you feel about yes how do you feel about
seeing everybody here tonight I'm going
to the early bird catches the worm but I
was gonna say you are here hurt a little
early well I'm here you know as it was
orchestrated with Bravo it's arranged to
what time I should be here I've sat
there at reunions and final parties when
the whole cast has been against me three
times so I've never shied away from it
before and I'm not sure I shouldn't
classic Vanderpump we love it we are
gonna ask everybody your question you
left them why tonight question what you
said to ask them why tonight Oh
why yeah why that's a good question I
think you should ask them
[Music]
[Applause]